we're gonna figure this out with a
girl's inspiring story of golf and
gratitude it took her all the way to the
Augustine National course that's home of
the Masters of course for nine-year-old
Madeleine Quinn the path to Augusta was
part of her bucket list that also
included getting a new heart and meeting
her Idol Tiger Woods lead National
correspondent David begno hit the links
with her to learn about her remarkable
Journey it's a journey of courage and
positivity
we met Madeleine Quinn on a chilly
drizzly morning in Southern California
and quickly found out there is nothing
that's going to dampen this girl's
Spirit when she's out on the golf course
what I like about it is
um whenever I hit a driver I mean I just
like feel pumped up and I'm ready and I
just like really like the challenge
do you feel like golf is your passion
yes it's your calling yes I love it
Madeline first picked up a club at two
whack
starting with a toy but quickly moving
to the irons the Love of the Game has
grown the passion has grown and now I
get to teach the little girl I love more
than anything in the world she has a
great built-in teacher and Dad and caddy
all-in-one her dad a former PGA Pro
started showing Maddie videos of Tiger
Woods golfing as a child
and says that's what inspired her this
is the girls junior Club championship
trophy there it is yeah there it is
Madeline Quinn
whenever I have a tournament my dad
always says what's the goal today I say
to have the most fun out here you love
doing it more than anything else yes to
go along with that Unstoppable smile is
a heart that is something of a modern
miracle you see Madeline was born with
what's called a ventricular septal
defect a hole in her heart she could not
gain weight her breathing was very very
rapid Madeleine underwent three open
heart surgeries as doctors tried to fix
her tiny heart it was the hardest thing
I've I've ever had to go through and
then it kept getting worse and worse and
worse at 18 months old Maddie was put on
a transplant list a complicating Factor
was that doctors said she needed a
bigger heart to maintain function
perhaps from a five-year-old well four
months later they got the call a perfect
match had been found the surgery was a
success and for the first time little
Maddie had rosy cheeks and even an
appetite all right so this Art's doing
well for you yeah and I just had my
eighth heart birthday oh you have heart
birthdays yeah I love that I've been
living my best life I'm so happy and
thankful Madeline wanted me to field Joy
she says she gets from golfing
she told me I needed the proper attire
so I asked if she could help me out yeah
you look amazing
with a nine-year-old driving on we went
I don't even know where it went so much
for this guy's Gulf dreams look at the
look on her face
but Dad wants Maddie to continue to live
hers drive for show but Fredo she wanted
to see tiger play in person so Dad
bought the tickets and Maddie
made a bucket list poster heart
transplant check meet Tiger Woods and
play in Augusta every golfer's Dream
well as luck would have it Tiger's caddy
spotted Maddie's sign and he whispered
something to woods and tiger looked he
read it and took out a Sharpie signed
his glove and then came toward me with a
pen and he checked the box and gave me
the glove
oh my goodness I'm usually really polite
but he's really really glove and my dad
said say thank you and I'm like so thank
you when he signs it and walks away what
were you thinking I was thinking wow
that really just happened I really just
meant the best golfer in the world oh
these are golf Metals yeah these are my
tournament medals that I won and her
prized possession that's his signature
wow girl all right yeah we're gonna
um frame it and about that final item on
her bucket list
someone close to Augusta spotted her
story on social media and invited her to
the Masters it was just so special that
I got to go there it was just so green
beautiful I wanted to go back on the
airplane and get my clubs and then fly
back and play all 18 holes while play
was suspended at times due to rain
Madeleine says she didn't mind getting
wet because she was focused on the golf
I was just like picturing me like
swinging like them and I'm like I could
be as good as them or even better one
day pushing through adversity from the
very beginning is what seems to have
given young Madeleine A sensitivity that
transcends her age I tell my story to
make people feel happy and not so
stressed out so you're happy to share it
yeah that's wonderful and in first place
Madeline Quinn her parents say they will
never forget the kindness of strangers
especially that family who gave their
young daughter
her heart there is hope there is some
good that can come from everything I
think of being a parent and saying we
want to give someone else life and
Maddie got to live a lot of gratitude so
grateful it's beyond words
I just adore that little kiddo now
listen it said play Augusta at the end
of The Bucket List she didn't get to
play this time but if that kid keeps
practicing the way I saw her swing I'm
telling you there's a good chance she's
gonna be a pro one day she walked all 18
holes at the Masters despite the rain
despite the fact that it was cold dad
said it was a magical experience
David it was magical just watching you
say you Adora we were all melting here
in the studio I love that moment with
Tiger Woods that you could capture it on
camera but most of all her driving I
loved everything about this little girl
in her family
Gail she's almost as good she's almost
as good as me with a golf club did you
see that no she was laughing at you
David yeah she was but she was laughing
at you but I do love David that she at
that age nine years old is telling you
that she is living her best life yeah
she is so thankful and happy may we all
live like that well past nine years old
I mean that's incredible yeah David
stick to the storytelling leave the golf
to her about great that was a great
piece I loved it Bravo Tony you should
have seen the first five swings that
didn't even connect with the ball
David we don't care about you in your
golf we care about little Maddie we
think it's so wonderful what you did and
Bravo to you both I wrote a tiger and
tiger and tiger wow that was great